the Arctic might soon become completely
ice-free and when all of the ice is gone
the world won't be the same but what if
I told you there was a way to prevent
this from happening and that we could do
it by geoengineering some artificial
icebergs this is what if and here's what
would happen if we could refreeze the
Arctic over the last 30 years the Arctic
has lost almost all of its oldest
thickest ice now 70% of the Arctic is
covered with thin seasonal ice caps that
shrink in the summer and grow back in
the winter by some estimates if the
earth continues to grow hotter the
Arctic could lose all its summer ice by
the year 2030 and this would affect more
than just the Arctic the Arctic works as
a global freezer keeping the planet cool
take all of that ice away and the
weather patterns around the globe would
change in a very unpredictable way
but it doesn't have to end like this we
could step in and regrow some of the
Arctic ice but how exactly would we go
about it the answer lies in
geoengineering we could bring the ice
back to the Arctic with the help of huge
wind powered pumps 10 million of them to
be precise the pumps would spread
seawater on to the glaciers where it
would freeze and form a new layer of ice
over one Arctic winter the pumps would
add another meter of thickness to the
ice caps but this would come with a
price tag of 500 billion dollars and
even though that's less than 1% of the
world's gross domestic product some
governments might consider the price too
high but there are other ways the polar
ice keeps the planet cool by reflecting
the sun's energy back into space rather
than absorbing it this is known as the
albedo effect we could help the young
Arctic ice to reflect more sunlight by
covering it with small shiny silica
microspheres these powder like
microbeads aren't toxic and their
chemical and physical properties are
similar to sand it would cost us just
300 million dollars to sprinkle 25,000
square kilometres of the Arctic but that
would only cover less than 1% of all the
ice there and we're talking about
dumping millions of tons of silica over
the Arctic that would sink to the bottom
of the ocean when the ice melted we
don't know yet what ecological impact it
might cause over time would you want to
risk losing the Arctic before performing
more tests I didn't think so
we could leave the ice alone and try
cutting off the sun's rays by using the
clouds but they would have to be very
thick to reflect the sunlight
efficiently enough this could be solved
by seeding the clouds above the Arctic
with droplets of salt water all we'd
have to do is figure out how to deliver
an ultra fine sea water mist into the
lower atmosphere or we could go further
and start growing icebergs first we dip
submarines below the surface of the
ocean and fill a tank with seawater an
on-board desalination system would
remove the salt from the water and then
a giant freezing machine would form
icebergs five metres thick and 25 metres
wide but despite how cool it sounds the
amount of energy required to power the
operation and the heat it would release
might negate any benefits of restoring
the Arctic ice so should we even bother
trying we could just quietly watch the
Arctic lose its ice to climate change
until eventually there wouldn't be any
ice left at all as temperatures rose the
Arctic permafrost would melt and release
more carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
that would increase the global
temperatures even further the weather
patterns across the planet would be sent
off course resulting in more floods or
droughts and more heat waves some
scientists even believe that the
ice-free Arctic would bring harsher
winters to Europe and North America and
who knows what else could happen
without ice to rest on polar bears would
be forced to swim around instead of
conserving their energy during times
when food can be hard to find that would
result in their population dropping to
less than 10,000 by 2050 it would be
fantastic if we could refreeze the
Arctic we should at least try to
refreeze a small portion of it but that
would only be a temporary bandage if we
continue doing the things that caused
the ice to melt in the first place it
really comes down to us making a
collective effort to switch to renewable
energy sources and energy-efficient
appliances to cut back on the amount of
meat we eat to stop throwing food away
to reduce water waste and to buy
electric or at least fuel-efficient cars
it's up to us to help our planet and if
that's not enough remember that you have
a right to demand policies that reflect
climate science together we could undo
climate change globally before it's too
late and if we don't start acting now we
might have to leave the earth and search
for another planet to call home
but that's a story for another what if
[Music]
you